so let's talk about the best way to make
up the damage
after you consume refined carbohydrates
i'm talking about the breads the pasta
the cereals the biscuits the waffles the
pancakes
those refined carbohydrates not that you
would ever get into those
refined carbohydrates but if you know
someone who is consuming those
you might want to send on this video so
they can then
make up the damage first question is
what is the damage of consuming refined
carbohydrates
well you're cramming a tremendous amount
of
fuel into the machine into the
mitochondria
and it's going to be overloaded with
electrons and other things okay
now at the same time because those
carbohydrates are refined
that means you don't get the benefit of
antioxidants
and nutrients that are normally supposed
to protect against this
oxidation and free radical damage
but now what happens is the mitochondria
because it can't
utilize this fuel there's a lot of
byproducts that occur
uh in the form of oxidants and free
radicals
and that is what causes the collateral
damage
the microvascular inflammation that
targets the
retina of the eye the kidney the heart
specifically the inside of the
arteries as well as your brain
and the nerves now that you know what
the damage is
what can we do to make up the damage
well antioxidants all right
most of the antioxidants that you're
going to get come from plant source but
you can also get them from
fish and seafood because omega-3 fatty
acids
can act as an antioxidant not to mention
other things like selenium
and even organ meats have significant
antioxidants in heart meat you have
very high levels of coenzyme q10 in fact
10 times that of tocopherols
which is part of the vitamin e complex
all right secondly
you do not want to get your antioxidants
from
synthetic vitamins specifically
synthetic antioxidants you may or may
not know this
but the majority probably 99.9
of all the vitamins sold you know like
the vitamin a
vitamin e vitamin c are made
synthetically
okay you do not want to get your
antioxidants from
those so-called nutrients why
because the studies that demonstrate
antioxidants actually increase your
mortality
are done with those synthetic
antioxidants
not from actual food antioxidants so
anytime
you take vitamins and you want to get
antioxidants make sure they're
a food concentrate or a natural
plant-based
type vitamin but not the synthetic
versions
if you want more information on that i
put a link down below
ideally you should get your antioxidants
from salad vegetables cruciferous
and a lot of herbs and even green tea is
a great thing to do
and at the same time you want to avoid
omega-6 oils
grains and animals who eat grains by the
way because it's high in omega
6 which is inflammatory ice cream
because you have you're combining fat
with sugar which is even
worse than consuming sugar chips which
is
fat and carbs not a good combination
creates a lot of inflammation
and then also when you combine like
protein with sugar
like barbecued ribs that type of thing
not a good combination because all that
increases inflammation
and free radical damage and not good
so when someone consumes refined
carbohydrates
we want to counter some of that damage
by consuming
at the same time antioxidant type foods
so after you consume a huge bowl of ice
cream and
a loaf of bread followed up with a huge
bowl of salad and that will reduce the
damage
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you how to
bulletproof yourself and so you can
tolerate and resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today